This side lenght is 3 times the square root of 39. Great problem solving for
getting that one right. Now 7, 24, 25 is a special right triangle that we could
use. But since this hypotenuse isn't 25, we won't use that. Instead, we'll just
need to use the Pythagorean Theorem. A squared plus b squared equals c squared.
In this case, 7 is the leg, 20 is the hypotenuse, since it's across from the
right angle, and x is the unknown leg we're trying to find. So, we'll have 7
squared plus x squared equals 20 squared. Squaring 7, we get 49 and squaring
20, we'll get 400. Next, we'll subtract 49 from both sides to get 1x squared
equals 351. We take the square root of both sides keeping only the positive
root. So, x is equal to the square root of 351. We can simplify this square
root by breaking it into 3 times 117. Then, we break it down one more time, to
get 3 times 3 times 39. We have a repeated factor of 3. So, a 3 comes outside
of our square root, and 39 stays inside. This gives us our final answer of 3
times the square root of 39.